scott disick is quote still processing
ex kourtney kardashian's engagement to
rocker travis barker i just
don't like
seeing you with another guy a source
tells e.t scott is quote also trying to
get under courtney's skin by being
spotted out and about
this after paparazzi snapped the reality
star clubbing with a young model
our source says scott is not dating
anyone seriously yet after his breakup
with amelia hamlin in september i think
you just have to read the press and
amelia did
but quote he is getting back to going
out and hitting the party scene again so
i figured this would be the move to make
and when it comes to the current status
of scott's relationship with the rest of
the kardashian jenner fam our source
adds quote scott is still very close
with chris he and chris talk to each
other all the time he will still be
included and welcomed in various
kardashian celebrations including
holidays as he is still their family but
right now he doesn't know if he will
choose to be around
we'll see
travis popped the question to courtney
on october 17th after less than a year
of dating this is such a dream come true
shortly after the engagement news broke
a source told e.t that scott the father
of court's three kids was not jumping
for joy
stating quote scott is stewing over
courtney and travis's engagement and not
happy at all he's lonely right now and
not in a relationship and is very
jealous that things are working out for
courtney scott would prefer to go back
to when he and courtney were just
getting along as co-parents without
anyone else in their lives romantically
i'm not like
i don't know i'm just like living life
and
whatever happens happens well a lot is
happening when it comes to the push
founder and her new fiance a source
tells e.t quote courtney and travis have
already started talking about wedding
planning and they're both so excited and
that they hope to get quote married
sooner than later eyeing a quote
intimate and small ceremony get excited
meanwhile travis recently got courtney's
lips tattooed where he once had his ex
shayna mokler's name and the two
lovebirds have been showing off just how
smitten they are by posting photos from
their stunning engagement on social
media i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day now back to
scott e.t spoke with the reality star in
2019 about co-parenting with courtney
and he opened up about how he's learned
to overcome the challenges they've faced
over the years
life is a challenge
and if you work at what you want you can
get it but it takes hard work simple as
that
you can easily live
less of a life without working as hard
and that's up to you
[Music]